the origins of st. Patrick I started
with a man named Niall of the Nine
Hostages who was an Irish pirate and
went about the British Isles capturing
people and bringing them back and
selling them as slaves so he went to
we're not sure whether he went to Wales
where he captured this man Patrick and
brought him back and sold him to a man
named milk ooh and Patrick was put out
in the hills of county antrim to serve
as a shepherd for about four or five
years he was a teenager when he was
captured and that's not a real name
Patrick that was not his name he was
from a patrician Roman family and
therefore he was known as the patrician
so when they wanted him to empty the
slop bucket or something like that if
they let the patrician do it so that's
how he got the name Patrick so anyway
I'm not sure what he's affection for
Ireland was a great wonderful poetic
literate pagan country and it had bards
and druids in the ascendancy and he
thought that they should all be
converted to Christianity so when he
escaped subsequently he went to France
to his uncle san martin of tours and
then he went to rome and he was
consecrated a bishop and then made his
way back to Ireland for 32 and ruined a
peppery good civilization
well he became he used the Shamrock
which is three leaves as the metaphor
for the Trinity of that belief you know
God the Father God the Son God the Holy
Ghost and so he held that up and in one
stem he used that as his illustration
and of course the Shamrock been green it
be token Green has been something but
his own color was blue and st. Patrick's
blue was is well known over the years it
was a day of holy day of obligation in
Ireland very little celebration my
memories of it are of a gloomy rainy
awful day when no matter what we had to
get up an hour earlier and go to Mass
and then go to school and face the same
old rubbish from being hit on the head
or beaten on the hands by because
corporal punishment was in order at the
time and I think it still is to us at
least it so it didn't change much but
then what happened over the years as it
became a holiday a big holiday here in
our big celebration I just another
holiday a celebration here in New York
tre said oh oh we should do something
about that so they decided to imitate
what it goes on here everything except
that the crowd here are somewhat and not
somewhat quite a homophobic and they
don't let the gays march as as a unit as
an identified unit whereas in Ireland
the home of the whole bloody thing is
the gay people get they get prizes and
awards for being the most colorful group
in parades so I think it's amazing